Обмін полоненими - одне із зобов'язань,
передбачених Мінськими угодами.
Щоправда, уже понад рік у цьому питанні
не було жодних зрушень.
Традиційно ця тема реанімується
перед новорічними святами.
Ось і нині активно обговорюється можливість
обміну 74-х українських військовополонених на
306 бойовиків угруповань "ЛНР" та "ДНР".
Чому цей процес такий мега-складний?
За даними СБУ, станом на листопад 2017 року
із сепаратистського полону звільнено
3140 українців.
Найбільше - після "Іловайского котла"
та операції довкола Дебальцевого.
Безпосередньо на лінії розмежування українській
стороні вдалося визволити близько 1 600 людей.
Точна кількість невідома, бо окрім СБУ про обмін з
бойовиками домовлялися і волонтери, і бойові
командири, і навіть деякі батьки самі приїздили
до сепаратистів з викупом за своїх дітей.
Вже понад рік родини полонених можуть бачити
своїх синів, чоловіків та братів хіба що
у сюжетах російського телебачення.
За даними СБУ, нині в полоні сепаратистів
перебуває 158 українців.
Місцеперебування 95-ти встановлено, і сепаратисти
визнали, що ці люди в них є.
Щодо решти 63-х - досі невідомо, де вони й які
групи бойовиків їх утримують.
Крім того, є ще величезна кількість
зниклих безвісти: за даними СБУ, це 403 людини,
волонтери ж заявляють про майже 700.
Із засідань Тристоронньої контактної групи
з мирного врегулювання ситуації на Донбасі
випливає, що причина - в узгодженні списків.
Бойовики вимагають видати їм серед іншого і
колишніх "беркутівців", відповідальних за злочини
на Майдані, і причетних до пожежі в
одеському Будинку профспілок.
Українська сторона такі вимоги категорично
відкидає, адже це ніяк не повязано з АТО.
Деякі експерти вважають, що обмін не в останню
чергу блокується Кремлем, адже українські
заручники - зручний спосіб тиску на Київ.
Про те, що Кремль контролює цей процес, свідчить
і те, що про актуальний обмін заговорили після
неформальної зустрічі кумів Володимира Путіна
та Віктора Медведчука.
Родичі військовополонених згодні на будь-яких
посередників, аби тільки їхні рідні повернулися додому.
Українська сторона неофіційно каже: ймовірність
того, що обмін таки відбудеться - 90 %.